quand il était question d'écrire ce
nouveau spectacle donc j'ai commencé à
tourner en janvier 2022 et moi ça me
rend besoin d'un an de faire un
spectacle et en janvier 2021 je me suis
dit mais pourquoi j'ai envie de parler
et en fait je me suis rendu compte que
j'avais plein de questionnements que je
me sentais très très vieille alors que
les gens disaient ma femme ah non tu es
pas bien et tu as 30 ans j'avais 32 ans
en fait à 32 ans et puis et puis du coup
de là est parti en fait ben c'est vrai
c'est un concert très marrant entre deux
ans de sentir très très vieille et de là
ben j'ai réfléchi à plein de choses on a
beaucoup discuté avec le co-auteur et le
metteur en scène et puis ben ça a donné
ça a donné ce spectacle et en fait j'ai
repensé à entre guillemets un peu toute
ma vie et qu'est-ce qu'elle dirait la
petite Manon comment elle me verrait et
puis de là pour découler mais plein de
sketchs et plein de thèmes en rapport
avec ça